et aujourd'hui on se trouve enfin sursis
forêt je vous en avais parlé il ya à peu
près petit jour sur twitter et
honnêtement j'attendais impatiemment ont
pu s'il a été repoussée de sept jours
sont là c'est la fin ok dans un avion 1
donc là pour le mans sait pas trop si
forest au pourquoi ça ne réveille pas la
boire manger fumer des gros coups
d'épaulé dans la tête tu as moins
vicieux quoi je vois avec true blood qui
est mon fils probablement qui dort comme
ça et moi je veux leur humanité mon dieu
jackson taxe ne sait pas où on va penser
avec les fesses du klaxon ou pas pour
ils arrêtent de penser à mon dieu
textron sais pas comment tu te lécher
les pieds assez horrible
qu'est ce que j'aime ripa me crachent
heures d'avion un temps qui aimeraient
disposer encore en vie bien sûr qu'on
est encore en vie ou là qu'est ce qui se
passe lui
bonsoir je te laisse la vie sauve ok
peut par contre je prends jackson
j'ai bien aimé ça danse ça danse des
fesses dans l'avion c'était mignon
elle est à + alors pas beaucoup
d'énergie trouver quelque chose à manger
bas on peut dire que on est bien tombée
c'est quoi une hache à une hôtesse de
l'air bâtarde
l'avion s'est crashé c'est de ta faute
alors l'avion et bien craché whaou on a
été jusqu'à juste à côté de la mer quoi
donc gg donne absolument aucune
information sur le jeu je pense que
c'est le moment de le faire l'appoint
des gages m'a fait peur ce qu'on sait un
survival horror dans un monde ouvert
tout simplement
et la particularité c'est qu'on peut
kraft et des trucs voilà par exemple
avec du bois on va fabriquer je sais pas
une cabane enfin je dis un peu n'importe
quoi bon je ramasse absolument tout ce
que je trouve et on fera le tri après ça
vous va je crois que voilà ça c'est
l'interface alors commencer par un
tutoriel jeu j'approuve totalement
shelter restera tourner énergie peut
être utilisé pour se cacher des
prédateurs et aussi pour sauvegarder la
partie ce qui est plutôt utile on peut
le dire ok donc il nous faut aussi
astier quatre trucs machins du bois je
suppose qu'il faut aller à base de base
de couper des arbres on va se poser sur
la plage on va être bien on va être bien
propres sur la plage est parti à oui
mais voilà on voit la petite en taille
allez allez allez nous résistent à bord
quoi [ __ ] mais là il âgé par balles ou
g les parages devrais je dire
c'est l'heure deux décédés à face aux
manifestations l'attestation la tête aux
oiseaux il ya des boîtes et mickaël go
round après round je teste le monde n a
pas de problème waf est pas de faire mon
gars tu t'es pris pour qu'ils quittent
aides quitte et il est ici quitter mais
attends mais je vais commencer une
partie que je me fais déjà agressé par
des gens nus quoi où est le problème
ils ne veulent pas faire ma démo de
danse des fesses qui m'agresse quoi ça
va ils m'ont fait peur c'est courant
chez moi je m'étais pris un rond d'un
poids mais pas du tout ah non mais on
voit que dalle la hâte de regarder tes
mains oui c'est des mains c'est bon ça
va on voit que dalle
l'aude est fan sommes médecine d'accord
ok d'accord je pars orma ok bah oui mais
je suis tombé dans un buzz mais bon
allez on recommence tapez vous avez
survie une journée je propose qu'on
recommence calmement c'est parti je vous
dis ah j'avais une vision on va tous
mourir vite fait quelque chose
alors cette fois je vais pas me faire
avoir deux fois de suite je préfère
[ __ ] y'a plus la plage là là pour
qu'on nous milieu de nulle part
mambé tout de suite de l'avion parce que
ça les a tous attirés je dégage d'ici
voit la ramasse tous les sticks que tu
vois même les stickers d'aiguiser leur
laideur jalons je vais couper un tronc
d'arbre que personne ne me dérange
il ya des tentes là-bas au nom mec
j'espère qu'ils sont pas là bas rhin
jean selles est une pouffe coucou peu ce
tronc d'arbre qui te plaît et ainsi voir
un arbre ne sais pas combien de mètres
tomber c'est peut-être pour ça qu'ils
sont venus quoi voilà il nous a fait une
petite willow le salto click to play on
va le mettre juste là what you un bruit
ya eu un bruit
ok je suis totalement parano le cas il
faudra que tu te détendre 2 j'aimerais
juste construit c'est sauvegarder comme
ça chez on est un minimum
ok c'est pas un petit qui fait l'objet
depuis quelques avions la grèce
directeur par contre là ya pas de pitié
je vois un mec s'approcher au ya un truc
à chasser la gfa au foot je suis désolé
bon j'avoue en vrai je m'en bats les
steaks mais je suivais à me désole yes
comme on fait dormir pour regarder de
l'énergie est sauvegardé oui z
yes non c'est la nuit au québec deuxième
étape basique fire il faut des feuilles
et deux sticks
on va mettre juste là en plein devant
abrapa oui
allez je me suis équipé d'une peau de
lézard ou tce pas trop quoi en tout cas
on restera plus aux hommes de l'ombre
maintenant faut que j'allume mais qui va
à coup de hache dans le firmware
d'allstate jamais de sauvegarder mais
moi je me dis qu'est-ce qu'il ya un peu
tâche et free bird
non non il faut dormir il faut dormir
dormir porte conseil [ __ ] du coup
c'est vrai la nuit je baigne dans le
sang il faut que je me lave pour pour
empêcher l'infection et on peut aussi
empêcher l'infection en brûlant
l'appeler normands 1 après voilà on va
faire cela on va faire meilleur feu il
ya un fou qui est mieux que l'autre la
up la moughataa un dangereux pyromane
merde vous l'avez vu
qu'est ce que je fais oh [ __ ] regarder
même le lapin il a vu il est parti en
courant je tombe bien caché là je dans
les plantes comme ça tu ne me vois pas
ils sont 2 n'arrive à me défoncer mais
se disent tiens un feu aux biens
d'oiseau aux ailes mois protège moins
oiseaux protège - qu'est-ce tu fais
qu'est ce que tu fais mon gars qu'est ce
tu peux tu sais pas qui je suis moi j'ai
défoncé des mecs comme toi
[ __ ] mais ça allait mais qui résiste à
mort quoi je m'en fous je m'en fous je
m'enfuis geffroy il faut que je retourne
vers le feu ils vont de capturer un nom
oh [ __ ] mais non mais l'auteur mais
juste un uppercut je mets vins coups de
hache et je décède
j'en ai marre oh non pas cette caverne
s'il vous plaît et bien une entrée
kekpart hop c'est bon un vrai on a le
hall alors on est bon là abonde intérêts
sur cette île à cause d'un crash d'avion
moi j'étais archéologues ils ont droit
comme ça je n'ai vu des pires j'espère
juste pas tombé sur un mec un peu chelou
et ben voilà on a trouvé une petite
sortie on est bon un nom vous trouvez
pas on va dire qu'on est à moitié vous
cédez sûr c'est que je peux négocier mon
fils avec ses sous je leur propose des
sous et même le libère on a trouvé des
dents à tort les flics adam il a fait
tant je prends juste et dans voilà merci
la sortie la sortie y avait un brut au
boom
qu'est ce tu dit ça à mon gars qu'est ce
tu dit ça tu saignes ça fait moins le
malin à temps il meurt au partant
puisque rappelons le match au cas où il
est décédé non brûlé est décédé à mais
en fait des mecs quoi être capture c'est
juste un périple de deux jours et demi
ou quoi pour s'enfuir je sens l'air
entre mes orteils les orteils but c'est
la sortie au nom oui allégé de cazaux
barricades mois on a réussi à s'enfuir
on va construire petite cabane à lait on
va construire cas qu'est ce tu fais
peut-être chez moi [ __ ] d'animal de
merde ça c'est fait ça mais comment
voulez je me défende condé si j'ai pas
de chez moi il faut chaud un chez moi
une petite cabane il faut 14 tic et 35
bois en mai pour huit années ni quoi
faire ça mais mais mais mais dégage
oiseaux s'te plaît je suis en train de
construire à ce que ça soit bordel il
faut du bois en masse à l'est ok on va
faire ça on va faire un stock juste là
moi je fais toujours un petit tour comme
ça c'est une sorte de techniques qui se
transmet de père en fils oh oh mais
c'est mon nom mon gars qu'est ce tu
dégage de là je suis à moins de conclure
c'est bon on a tout ce qu'il faut on
peut construire notre renner mois ou un
petit jardin regarder offert un petit
jardin on va faire un petit jardin on va
construire ce petit michael et ça a
poussé vasic huila au plat et puis voilà
it et voilà on a mangé a plus qu'assez
général hôpital est immense hulet va me
rapporter de terrain regardez moi quoi
je suis l'arbre qui pèse
j'aimerais bien que les rondins tombe
directement sur la cabane on est bon là
ça commence à ressembler à quelque chose
ou pas du tout on peut se faire un
bateau et un très gros bateaux et la rd
super vite en plus j'ai ce qu'on va
faire on va faire ça va se faire un
piège aucune idée d'où le met mais non
non pour bah tant pis voilà il sera la
cédule à chier comme endroit tu te
manque wah wah t il a voulu me tuer or
le problème qu'ont fait vidéo sur un jeu
comme ça c'est bien évidemment savez
extrêmement tôt a construit le moindre
truc donc obligé de jouer pendant deux
heures pour finalement vous montrer que
trois minutes qua non il va pas quitter
ma cabane a assez bon c'est un jeu qui
joue uniquement en solo donc si vous
comptiez vous connecter pour venir
m'aider à couper du bois
eh bien vous ne pouvez pas voilà bel air
au sport parce que j'avoue que j'aurais
j'ai cru voir un mec là bas je vois un
mec là bas espagne blague une fois mort
du stick pour faire ce piège comme ça
s'ils viennent ban ils se font embaucher
sur les clous moi je dois d'aller en
train de faire un jeu c'est que j'ai
envie de voir ça et vous savez que j'ai
aussi envie de voir ça qu'est ce que tu
fais là est maintenant très ça a de la
gueule ou pas ah ok c'est si court vers
là ça se redresse et bonjour c'est rien
bourges courir autour du pièce si jamais
je vous fais pour 6 qui à savoir en
essayant de table pro ben vas-y je suis
moins souvent dans le piège pour toi le
piège françois le piège françois piège
les compagnonnages plutôt piège tous
trois pièces pour défendre
vous êtes chez moi vous attire moins
c'est mon territoire ici
c'est mon territoire vous avez pas droit
faut qu'ils passent là en fait vas-y
vient à temps mais cet homme s'appelle
comment hulk commence à nos jours on
avait passé tant de temps à écouter du
bois jackson
je voulais être sauvées jackson
difficile beaucoup sur vous propose de
faire la danse des fêtes en hommage à
jackson wever de l'agencé dia phone 7
frères vidéo sur la fin de six forêts
sont honnêtement je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un truc à faire sur ce jeu si
vous voulez une deuxième vidéo n'hésitez
pas à aimer celle ci et si vous avez
aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à aller
mais ce qui est totalement l'eau non
sans déconner je suis vraiment intéressé
pour faire deuxième vidéo sur ce jeu
mais je peux pas je me préparais un peu
à l'avant cela c'était vraiment
découvert mais si je fais une deuxième
vidéo
j'aurais déjà ma cabane tout ça avec des
têtes de ces 2 cm qui m'ont tué à pour
brancher sur des piques un peu partout
et on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo quoi qu'il arrive sur le
monde
pis
[Musique]
et
c'est
[Musique]
et